five it's a big day in football here in
the valley the nation's oldest college
football All-Star Game hits a legion
Stadium oh that's right it is the 98th
East West Shrine bull Candace Charles
joining us live from the stadium with
what skin the NFL has in the game oh
real quick Candace are you ready I want
to try and throw you the ball you ready
for uh for a little toss here three two
here we go TV Magic
oh
God
I got it man because we practice what in
our fellow real people who know how to
do this we'll be here tonight more than
100 nearly 150 players really from all
over the nation the best of the best
they're going to be vying to get some
spots on the NFL oh my gosh it's kind of
crazy right but it's really about the
Shriners children's and it's really a a
collaboration between the two just
seeing some of the children talk about
the players I could tell it's been great
experience now I have someone with me
who I'm sure you guys have seen quite a
few times I would say I like right but
you may not know his story so tell us I
like a little bit about your story yeah
I appreciate the time for having me I'm
Alex I suffer from osteogenesis
imperfective Little bone disease and
I've been attending the shriness
hospitals in Chicago since I was two
months old they've helped me with
physical therapy surgeries they've been
my second family and I can't thank them
enough oh that is Amazing Alec we love
always seeing you in the commercials you
always have such a wonderful spirit and
we may eventually see him doing some
sports news too guys I'll be really
excited about that as well it's great to
always hear the Next Generation we also
have Hunter here with us you can tell he
plays football right so he's been out
here all week as well for us for the
last couple of days tell me really what
the experience it's been like so far
um overwhelming to say the least you
know it's not every day you get to come
to Vegas and experience something like
this
um especially at this measure you know
Shriners they do you know a lot for
everybody not just myself but you know
these other patients and these football
players that are going to have you know
opportunities to get to the next level
and you know make something of
themselves so I'm forever grateful for
Shriners to definitely say that so uh
little bit Hunter that was so nice and
you know this is his first time getting
on a plane his mom was telling me that
it's wonderful I was telling me that so
it's exciting to have these guys out
here now Hunter we're gonna do a little
toss ourselves because we've been
practicing and he actually has a guitar
I'm gonna let you toss it to me and
while I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do a
little running a little running a little
running and the game kicks off at 5 30
tonight let's see if I can actually
catch it for the first time
the real people tonight at 5 30 like I
said there's still tickets they started
about 25 bucks we got details for you on
website.com okay now now that you guys
are done laughing at me you guys can
continue you know no I know wear helmets
on the field Candace I'm I I know did
you see my head like don't call it
Candace when I when Devante Adams is on
the field for the Raiders yes as he's
about to catch a ball it usually screams
out loud it squeals
thank you Candace appreciate that and uh
excellent work Bravo 6 39